Welcome to the Beginning Android
nanodegree.
My name's Chris and
I'm a curriculum lead here at Udacity.
>> And my name is Katherine, and
I'm a developer advocate at Google.
>> There are over 1.4 billion
active Android devices today.
So becoming an Android developer
means being able to build software
that can reach and impact the lives
of tons of users around the world.
>> Yeah, this is a pretty incredible
time in history because mobile
apps are changing the way
that we live and work.
So we're super excited that you're
taking the first step to becoming
a developer.
For this nanodegree you don't
need any programming experience.
If you know how to use a computer and
a smartphone, you're ready to go.
>> Yeah, that's right.
No programming experience needed.
So if you ever had an awesome idea for
an app but
didn't know how to get started,
then this is the program for you.
>> We'll walk you through how to
build several simple Android apps.
And along the way, you'll learn
the Java programming language and
also some key computer science concepts.
>> Yeah, we're going to focus
on what's important and
how to directly apply what you've
learned to the apps you're building.
>> It's going to be challenging,
and that's expected, but
that's why we're going to teach
you how to think like a developer.
We'll explain the decisions
that arise in building an app.
You'll learn how to read documentation,
search for online resources,
plan out your tests, and
also figure out how to get unstuck.
>> And signature to every
nanodegree experience,
you'll also have the opportunity to
complete projects on your own and
get invaluable feedback on your code.
>> And by the end of the program, you'll
have completed a whole portfolio of
apps that you can share with
your family and friends.
>> We hope that you become
inspired to learn more and
go on to build some great apps.
>> Yeah, let's go get started.
>> Let's do it.